I want to bring some breaking news now
concerning Prince Harry Buckingham
Palace confirming that claims have been
filed on behalf of the Duke of Sussex at
the High Court so this is all regarding
the illegal interception of voicemail
messages our royal correspondent
Rhiannon Mills can join us on the line
Rhiannon what are you hearing
so we've literally in the last 10
minutes also had this confirmation
through from Buckingham Palace in which
they say that they can confirm that
claims have been filed on behalf of the
Duke of Sussex at the High Court
regarding the illegal interception of
voicemail messages they go on to say
that they won't be making any further
comment on that given that the
particulars of claims are not yet public
but when you go online now you can find
details all claims which have been put
in by Prince Harry you can see on the
website that the claims have been made
against newsgroups newspapers limited
and also the Mirror Group Newspapers
limited of course this comes after what
has been a tumultuous week when it comes
to Prince Harry's relationship with the
press we found out just a couple of days
ago while him and Megan were on their
successful tour of southern Africa who
found out that the couples were
launching legal action against the mayor
on Sunday that was after they published
a letter which Megan had written to her
father
following the fact that he wasn't able
to attend their wedding and accompanying
that announcement that they were
launching that legal action we had that
10 paragraph statement from Prince Harry
which many have interpreted as a tirade
against the press him saying that he has
had enough when it comes to the
continual misrepresentations that are
facing Megan saying that there has been
this repeated propaganda against his
wife and also saying that he fears the
worst when it comes to the press simply
playing a game with his wife's life and
alluding to the fact that of course his
mother he believes was commoditized by
the press when she was alive and that he
fears history repeating itself
just to confirm in the last 10 minutes
or so we have heard from Buckingham
Palace that claims have been filed on
behalf of the Duke of Sussex at the High
Court regarding the illegal interception
of voicemail messages of course this
also reminds us back in around 2014
during the height of the phone hacking
scandal regarding the news the world the
Royals were heavily involved in that it
transpired that Prince William and
Prince Harry's voicemails had been
intercepted and as a result stories
would appear in the newspapers so again
we're hearing this evening that Prince
Harry has now lodged those complaints in
the High Court again at news
international news group and also mirror
news group as well